all right washington trying to win the
division they're six and eight
in first place by one game any of the
four teams can win it
they've got an issue now they've got a
good old distraction
dwayne haskins after the 20-15 loss to
the seahawks on sunday
apparently allegedly whatever was
number one at a strip club which is no
big deal he's a grown man he can do
whatever he wants number two
violating the covet protocols that the
nfl put in place for going to a club you
have to have on ppe the pictures of him
no ppe and you can only go to a place
where there's fewer than 10 people who
knows how many people were at this club
but it's obvious that haskins did
something
for which he's in trouble because once
the reports emerged that there was an
incident and the washington football
team is aware and they're dealing with
it haskins
tweeted an apology i think he's also
since deleted his twitter account
but that doesn't take away the apology
the apology
happened and uh basically he
acknowledges that
that he did something he shouldn't have
done there it is i want to publicly
apologize for my actions this past
sunday i spoke with coach rivera
yesterday
and took full accountability for putting
the team at risk
he was irresponsible and immature of me
and i
accept responsibility for my action i
also want to apologize for creating a
distraction
for my team during our playoff push i
will learn and grow from this
and do what's best for the team moving
forward i mean yeah
regardless of a pandemic it's not a
great look when you lose a football game
to be
going out and partying anywhere but
that's okay again they're grown men they
can choose what they want to do i don't
care about that the bigger issue is
potentially getting himself
infected and potentially bringing it
back to the team and
somehow we've gotten 15 weeks of
football in shireen
even though plenty of guys have done
plenty of
dumb things that we know about and that
we surely
don't know about
well thank goodness we've gotten in this
many weeks mike but
yeah washington has a huge question at
the quarterback position and while they
hope that alex smith can start
are they going to start dwayne haskins
if alex smith can't start
and i do think that's a question at this
point and you know what is his future in
in washington
um what do they think of him this is
like the third
dumb thing that he's done he was already
fined i think earlier this year for
violating
covet uh protocols and remember we
remember the selfie last year when colt
mccoy had to go out and take the last
snap because he's over there taking a
selfie with the fan i mean just
he continues to do dumb things even
after ron rivera
questioned uh before the season his
leadership and then during the season
questioned his preparedness his work
ethic and encouraged him
and they thought drafting him with that
15th pick that they could
get the most out of him by challenging
him and that obviously hasn't worked
it looked like it was going to and then
it didn't and he didn't react well to
when he was
benched and he went from being starter
to street clothes for the washington
football team
this was an opportunity for him to
rebuild his career
for the washington football team to
potentially
build some trade value going into the
off season you know there was talk that
would maybe trade him before the
deadline
the tuesday after week eight you're not
going to get anything different from him
during the season than what you're going
to get after the season if anything
maybe you can get more after the season
because more teams will put together a
competitive package and try to get him
and they're going to analyze his film
it all kind of happens on the fly and
maybe in a little bit of a rushed
fashion
during the season so i still think
they're going to try to trade him this
probably makes them more likely to try
to trade him the problem is
this kind of behavior shireen makes his
trade value
less than it otherwise would have been
and i i go back to the old chris carter
all he does is catch touchdowns when
buddy ryan
finally had to cut the court on the
eventual hall of fame receiver
to give him that wake-up call teams
would much rather
apply the wake-up call to the guy
while he's on the team and hope that he
finally gets it and figures it out
than having him get that wake-up call
somewhere else with haskins i think
washington's just come to the
conclusion there's no wake up call to be
had and we'll see whether or not they
can unload him
onto a different team and we'll see what
kind of an issue it may be
as they move forward this week we're
waiting to see the
injury reports in advance of sunday's
game between carolina and washington
will alex smith be good to go he missed
last week's game they really need him to
play especially if there's any sort of
of discomfort and disappointment and
just general disdain for dwayne haskins
in the wake
of what happened shireen so i still
think washington win the division
and who knows maybe maybe this is a
moment the proverbial teachable moment
for dwayne haskins that makes him
more mature i just think if washington
had seen
anything positive this year he wouldn't
have been benched in the first place
well that's exactly right mike after
week four he got benched and then he
violated the covet
protocols it was fine almost about five
thousand dollars remember he made that
reservation
uh for a family friend at the team hotel
so it just seems like a
pattern of things with dwayne haskins
and can't do the smart thing
you always need that that friend that
little angel sitting up on your shoulder
who says hey this isn't a good look we
need to do the right things
but that little friend is supposed to be
the quarterback he's supposed to be the
team leader and even after ron rivera
questioned his leadership he doesn't
seem to be leading for this team
and he hasn't learned obviously from
alex smith who is a great leader
of the washington football team so i
don't know
if there is going to be a wake-up call
but i don't know that it's going to be
in washington if there is one there have
just been too many of these incidents
where
you finally throw up your hands and say
go do it for somebody else if you can
we're done
i'm mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports